These days, it feels like every sci-fi film
ever made has been followed up by another.
For some reason or another, though, there
are some sci-fi movies that either never got
a sequel or ended up stopping a whole franchise
in its tracks.
Here are a few of those movies.
In E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial, a lonely suburban
boy named Elliott discovers a friendly alien
in the woods, with whom he soon forms an indelible,
psychokinetic bond.
It became the highest-grossing movie of its
time, received nine Academy Award nominations,
and solidified director Steven Spielberg as
the premier filmmaker of his generation.
In fact, pretty much the whole world fell
in love with the little alien man with the
glowing heart, meaning Spielberg and screenwriter
Melissa Mathison had to at least entertain
the notion of an E.T. sequel.
Together, they wrote a nine-page outline for
E.T. II: Nocturnal Fears, a movie very unlike
the original E.T. - in that it was a sci-fi
horror movie that barely featured E.T. at all.
The plot revolved around some other aliens
who receive E.T.'s distress call from the first movie.
Elliott and Gertie quickly track them down,
thinking E.T. has returned.
But these aliens are actually Gremlin-like
monsters with red eyes and sharp teeth who
end up torturing the kids.
Using his bond with E.T., Elliott calls for
help, and his alien pal shows up just in time to save them.
Apparently, Spielberg quickly realized that
this was all a really, really bad idea.
As he once said at an American Film Institute
event:
"Sequels can be very dangerous because they
compromise your truth as an artist.
I think a sequel to E.T. would do nothing
but rob the original of its virginity."
First published in 1982, Battlefield Earth
is an incredibly long and complex sci-fi epic
by Scientology founder L. Ron Hubbard.
Set in the year 3000, it tells the story of
Earth's 1000-year occupation by monstrous
humanoid aliens called Psychlos [SY-klohs],
who've reduced humanity to a population of
around 30,000... that is, until noble hero
Jonnie Goodboy Tyler sparks a revolution and
gains himself an enemy in Terl, the wicked
chief of Psychlo security.
John Travolta tried to get a film adaptation
of Battlefield Earth going for more than 15
years, only finally amassing the Hollywood
capital needed to make it happen in the late 1990s.
Unfortunately, this was too for Travolta to
play the role of Tyler as he'd hoped, and
he was instead cast as Terl.
He was also a producer on the project, and
had intended to tell the Battlefield story
over the course of two films.
Despite some fancy special effects and Travolta's
star power, however, Battlefield Earth crashed.
Made with a budget of $73 million, it took
in an Earth-wide total of $29 million.
And the few who did see the movie hated it.
It's got a 3% score on Rotten Tomatoes, and
it "won" in every category in which it was
nominated at the Razzies.
As a result, the sequel simply never got off
the ground.
Opening over the Fourth of July weekend in
1996, the original Independence Day packed
in all the elements of a perfect popcorn movie,
with special effects, an all-star cast, and
a crowd-pleasing plot in which humans pull
together to expel and eliminate an extraterrestrial menace.
The film earned a then-record $104.3 million
in its opening week, and took in a total of
$306 million in North America alone.
A sequel, then, was inevitable, but it still
took 20 years to get going.
Independence Day: Resurgence hit theaters
in the summer of 2016 and eked out an American
grand total of $103 million — less than
what the original film had pulled in during
its first week, and that's before you adjust
for inflation.
There are several reasons why Resurgence underperformed.
It's likely that Will Smith passing on the
sequel turned off audiences, and the 20 year
wait between films can't have helped, either.
Regardless, before the release of Resurgence,
director Roland Emmerich discussed his plans
for a third Independence Day movie, one that
would take Jeff Goldblum's character into
space to lead an attack on hostile aliens.
"Take the fight to them."
"When do we leave?"
"We are going to kick some serious alien ass."
But the lackluster numbers for Resurgence
seem to have killed any possibility of that happening.
Resurgence producer Dean Devlin told LMR Online
in 2018:
"Currently, I personally have no plans on
doing another one."
Disney already controlled a number of major
movie brands and franchises when it finalized
its acquisition of 21st Century Fox in March
2019.
That said, the Fox buyout was still a huge
deal in the industry.
Included in the $71 billion price tag were
the film rights to the X-Men, 30 percent of
Hulu, ownership of The Simpsons, and the difficult
decision on what to do with nearly 300 films
that had been in development at Fox.
One of those films was a sequel to Chronicle,
the innovative found-footage sci-fi about
three teenagers who find themselves wielding
incredible telekinetic abilities.
The 2012 original earned $126 million at the
worldwide box office, but when Disney acquired
the property, they clearly didn't think the
franchise had much of a future.
Still, seven years had passed between the
release of Chronicle and the Disney acquisition.
Why didn't Fox make a sequel in the interim?
Well, it probably has a lot to do with the
creative minds behind the first film.
For one, screenwriter Max Landis was accused
of sexual assault in 2017, and since then,
his career has pretty much disintegrated.
Meanwhile, director Josh Trank admitted to
Collider that he intentionally made things
hard when Fox asked about a sequel.
He said:
"I made it difficult for them to set up meetings.
I was dodgy about stuff.
[...] Because I really didn't ever want to
see Chronicle 2 happen.
That was my worst nightmare."
Once upon a time, Disney thought that the
whole world was ready for a sci-fi epic based
on a forgotten, century-old book.
Andrew Stanton of Pixar convinced Disney to
buy the rights to Edgar Rice Burroughs' 1912
novel A Princess of Mars and then let him
direct the adaptation, even though he'd never
made a live action movie.
Disney sunk $263.7 million on the production
of John Carter - plus another $100 million
on marketing - making it one of the most expensive
movies ever made.
That's a lot of cash to invest in a film based
on an obscure property... and starring a cast
of relative unknowns, to boot.
Released in March 2012, critical reviews for
John Carter were middling at best, and they
did nothing to entice audiences to what was
already a hard sell.
After a moderately robust $30 million opening
the weekend, the film sank fast and wound
up bringing in just $73 million in the U.S.
It didn't do much better overseas, either,
with a final global take of $284 million.
Disney's massive financial losses made John
Carter into one of the biggest bombs of all
time, thus putting the brakes on the development
of any of the ten additional books in Burroughs' "Barsoom" saga.
In 2014, the rights to the series reverted
back to the author's estate, putting any last
chance of a John Carter sequel firmly in the
ground.
Based on a cancelled 1960s TV series that
ran for only three years, Star Trek: The Motion
Picture hit the big screen in 1979, a testament
to the property's devoted and enduring fan base.
Through the '80s and '90s, Star Trek became
one of the most successful and long-lasting
film franchises of all time.
"Khaaaaan!"
Then, in 1994, the cast of the original six
movies passed the torch to a new generation
of heroes with the aptly-named 1994 film Star
Trek: Generations.
The first three films in the rebooted series
performed well at the box office, bringing
in an average return of $129 million.
Interest dropped off precipitously, however,
with the release of Star Trek: Nemesis in December 2002.
The fourth Next Generation movie took in $67
million at the U.S. box office - a respectable
number, but not all that great in comparison
to its predecessors.
As such, the movie killed Star Trek at the
multiplex for the time being, with part of
the blame falling to competition from several
other franchises.
At the time of its release, Nemesis faced
competition from The Lord of the Rings: The
Two Towers, Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets, and The Santa Clause 2.
As a result, the Star Trek franchise faded
into the ether - and didn't make a resurgence
until J.J. Abrams rebooted the series seven
years later.
Hellboy was a major hit character for indie
comic publisher Dark Horse.
The character is a red-skinned, super-powered
half-demon who works for the Bureau for Paranormal
Research and Defense, and in doing so, protects
Earth from creatures and forces of pure evil.
Fantasy icon Guillermo del Toro wrote and
directed 2004's Hellboy and Hellboy II: The
Golden Army, but he wasn't hired for a third
film.
Star Ron Perlman didn't want to make the movie
without del Toro either, so producers opted
to reboot the series instead, bringing on
a new creative team and replacing Perlman
with David Harbour, the likable breakout star
of the Netflix mega-hit Stranger Things.
Critics don't often praise sci-fi monster
movies, but they loved del Toro's two Hellboy
movies, which earned Rotten Tomatoes scores
of 81% and 86%, respectively.
Audiences also enjoyed the first Hellboys
to the tune of a combined $260.2 million at the box office.
The 2019 Hellboy, however, failed to capture
the hearts of either critics or filmgoers.
Reviewers savaged the movie, which brought
in just $44.6 million at the worldwide box
office in its first theatrical run.
This attempt at a fresh, rebooted franchise
simply crashed and burned — sending any
possibility of a sequel straight to hell.
It really does feel like the Terminator franchise
is impossible to kill.
"I'll be back."
It all started with 1984's sci-fi noir flick
The Terminator, starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
as a cyborg sent back in time to kill Sarah
Connor and her unborn son, John, who will
one day lead the human resistance against
the machines.
Terminator 2: Judgement Day found Schwarzenegger
playing a different time-hopping Terminator
entrusted with protecting teenage John Connor
from another, deadlier Terminator.
And so it went, with more Terminator installments
digging up more and more holes in the mind-boggling
timeline - all leading up to 2019's Terminator:
Dark Fate.
Despite the brand recognition, and despite
being the first Terminator in decades to feature
both Schwarzenegger and Linda Hamilton, Dark
Fate was a flop.
It was the first in the series since the 1984
original to not clear $350 million at the
box office, grossing just $261 million worldwide
- a number even more disappointing considering
it cost $185 million to produce.
Although you should never say never with a
franchise this big, those measly returns could
mean that the Terminator franchise has finally
met its fate.
The Hollywood icon Mel Brooks' best films
tended to parody entire genres of movies - Westerns
with Blazing Saddles, for example, or classic
horror with Young Frankenstein.
Naturally, then, in the 1980s, he turned his
hand to Star Wars.
Spaceballs lovingly sent-up the George Lucas
saga, but also pointed out just how silly
it all was, with Rick Moranis as the unsure,
Darth Vader-esque Dark Helmet, Bill Pullman
as the on-the-nose Han Solo parody Lone Starr,
and John Candy as the Chewbacca-like Barf.
Brooks himself even shows up for an extended
cameo as Yogurt, an old and wise Yoda rip-off
who's literally just there to sell merch.
"Spaceballs the coloring book, Spaceballs
the lunch box, Spaceballs the breakfast cereal,
Spaceballs the flamethrower!"
"Ooooh!"
Naturally, considering the franchise it's
spoofing, Spaceballs also promises a sequel
in Spaceballs 2: The Search for More Money.
Sadly, this will probably never happen, since
many members of the original cast have passed
away since the first film's 1987 release.
Most importantly of all, however, Moranis
has almost entirely retired from acting.
And as the 94-year-old Brooks once told Parade
magazine:
"Without Rick, I wouldn't do it."
And though Moranis has recently returned to
the screen for a few select projects, that's
most likely the end of that.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.